[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti a tutti e molte
grazie per l'invito a proposito di lumi
e di luci quelle che si stanno spendendo
adesso e quelle che è il fantasma lo
spirito di poco fa evocato uno dei
cleavage delle fratture importanti che
stanno ridefinendo e riconfigurando e la
politica oggi è proprio quella tra i
derivati le conseguenze l'eredità della
epoca dei lumi dell'illuminismo e la
tradizione ed è in qualche modo come se
venissimo scaraventati indietro nel
tempo in un tempo nel quale stiamo
parlando del settecento era molto chiaro
quale fosse il confine dove si dovesse
stare di qua o di là per l'appunto per
usare un'espressione molto comune molto
in voga da una parte c'era il lungo
depositato della tradizione quindi
l'idea di un tempo che non si modifica
di un tempo naturalmente religioso di
una comunità strutturata organica che
non si apre e che rimane stabile nel
tempo regalando identità e invece è un
secolo nuovo e 700 quello che apriva la
strada alla possibilità del progresso al
cambiamento appunto alle luci che
avrebbero rischiarato come dicevano gli
illuministi l'oscurantismo dei secoli
bui e queste tradizioni che non
consentivano all'individuo di essere
libero e se ci pensate è esattamente
quello che si ripropone nella nostra
epoca di post politica tanto
l'illuminismo aveva inaugurato l'idea
della politica razionale
l'idea della politica fatta attraverso
la ragione come sapete tanto oggi
nell'epoca della post politica ci
troviamo appunto scaraventati
all'indietro
in questo caso retrocediamo senza
avanzare per citare il magnifico
intervento del professor of o di poco fa
retrocediamo senza avanzare e ci
troviamo appunto precipitati nella
stessa dimensione di scambio perché la
politica è sempre negoziazione scambio
in termini anche virtuosi e naturalmente
non pensiamo solamente a quello che dal
punto di vista della crono
a corrente evoca la parola scambio lo
scambio tra la sicurezza e la libertà
l'epoca dei populismi e è un'età un'era
nella quale le persone chiedono invocano
fortemente maggiore sicurezza e sono
disponibili a rinunciare alla libertà a
restringere a farsi restringere quelle
condizioni e quegli ambiti di
emancipazione individuale come dicevano
gli illuministi nel nome della
possibilità la possibilità che non
significa necessariamente la realtà di
essere più sicuri di essere più
tranquilli di vedere salvaguardata la
propria sicurezza e naturalmente
sicurezza è un concetto molto ampio
polisemico va dall idea nella
contemporaneità della incolumità
personale
la sicurezza fisica all'idea del potere
pensare al futuro proprio e delle
generazioni dei figli e dei nipoti con
un po di tranquillità e di serenità
dal punto di vista economico la
sicurezza per l'appunto sociale però
quella che stiamo analizzando è una
letteralmente una storia di paradossi
una storia di contraddizioni perché se
l'illuminismo ha concepito le due grandi
rivoluzioni liberali con la sua
straordinaria rottura la rivoluzione
americana e la rivoluzione francese che
fu la rivoluzione dei filosofi come
sappiamo tutti quanti
una rivoluzione in cui la dimensione
della propaganda e della filosofia
politica che si ripensava è stata così
decisiva è stata una rivoluzione fatta
di proselitismo e di reinvenzione del
sapere attraverso quell opera colossale
di ridefinizione del nostro modo di
pensare che è stata linsey clop e di è
il primo grande paradosso che ci
troviamo davanti ed è un paradosso di
cui scontiamo le conseguenze anche oggi
che viviamo in un'epoca post moderna che
riproduce moltissimi tratti della pre
modernità e che in realtà sono stati
rivoluzionari francesi i costituenti e i
legislatori della rivoluzione del 1789 e
degli anni successivi a inventare il
popolo perché qui lo possiamo dire visto
che
come diceva il nostro presentatore siamo
comunque all'interno di una stanza e se
lo dicessimo fuori invece rischieremo
qualche pericolo il popolo non esiste il
popolo è una invenzione è un artificio
lo possiamo constatare tutti i giorni
nella nostra esperienza quotidiana
cos'è il popolo noi siamo una società
fatta di individui di famiglie di gruppi
di ceti e di raggruppamenti sociali
un tempo i sociologi soprattutto quelli
più allineati ad una certa visione
politica avrebbero detto classi termine
che oggi non si utilizza più viviamo una
società fatta di corpi intermedi di
associazioni siena è una città in cui
l'associazionismo è particolarmente
forte come in altre realtà della terza
italia ricche di capitale sociale
ma questo popolo non lo si vede da
nessuna parte
il popolo per l'appunto un artificio
il popolo è una creazione quindi anche
un feticcio nell'era dei populismi che i
legislatori francese del 1789 dovettero
creare per rilegittimare il proprio
potere e per rilegittimare un
importantissimo cambio di fase
dal punto di vista dei rapporti di
potere dei rapporti gerarchici
all'interno della società
una nuova classe sociale come sapete
benissimo la borghesia aveva acquisito
stava acquisendo il potere e lo faceva
insieme all'altro numericamente ben più
ampio pezzo di terzo stato la borghesia
e le fasce popolari i ceti subordinati
come si sarebbe detto nel novecento
costituivano insieme il terzo stato
quello costretto a restare in fondo alla
piramide sociale dall'aristocrazia e
dalla chiesa dagli aristocratici e dai
chierici e allora per legittimare il
proprio potere
i rivoluzionari francesi compiono una
straordinaria operazione devono
costruire un nuovo pilastro di
legittimità che sei in grado di sfidare
il legittimismo dell'antico regime
dell'ansietà
il la fonte della legittimazione del
potere dell'antico regime era duplice ed
era fortissima saldissima strutturata
lungo i secoli del cambiamento europeo
da un lato c'era una dimensione
trascendente e naturalmente sfidare la
trascendenza è un problema molto
difficile nel settecento ma è una stata
una sfida così importante così rilevante
che dopo averla vinta è iniziata l'epoca
della secolarizzazione era il diritto
divino si governava si deteneva il
potere sulla base di un investitura
proveniente dal principio trascendente
dalla divinità e l'altro era un
principio non così forte ma estremamente
solido era quello della trasmissione
dinastica ovvero della perpetuazione
ereditaria era il diritto del sangue in
questo caso il re trasmetteva il diritto
di governare nel nome di quel sangue
speciale assolutamente privilegiato è
assolutamente unico che trasmetteva alla
propria discendenza
ecco perché i rivoluzionari devono
inventarsi un principio di
legittimazione altrettanto forte è
altrettanto artificiale e altrettanto
artificioso devono costruire come
diremmo oggi una nuova narrazione
abbastanza evocative suggestiva da poter
reggere il confronto e la competizione
con queste due precedenti e in ogni caso
artificiale come quest è qui che nasce
il popolo come sapete nasce sulla base
della idea di una impresa comune che
diventa narrazione epica grazie alla
quale l'antico regime viene scalzato e
il nuovo soggetto sociale effettivamente
detentore del potere
il ricostruttore dei rapporti gerarchici
dei rapporti di forza
la borghesia sostiene di essere tutt'uno
con l'altro larghissimo pezzo di società
che era stato escluso fino in quel
momento dai rapporti di potere
dell'antico regime
ed effettivamente però la rivoluzione
francese costruisce quel principio di
uguaglianza giuridica di fronte alla
legge e di fronte al diritto la rule of
law come la chiamano gli anglosassoni
che avrebbe poi fondato
illuministicamente l'idea della
democrazia libera alla rappresentativa
un concetto oggi messo fortissimamente
in crisi in risonanza per l'appunto
dalla sfida portata dai populismi e dai
neo populismi questa uguaglianza
giuridica presupponeva che tutti gli
individui tutti i singoli fossero per
l'appunto chiamati a godere degli stessi
diritti e naturalmente anche degli
stessi doveri di fronte ad un giudice
e questo è un altro dei tanti paradossi
di questo cambiamento dei concetti e
delle dottrine politiche perché se fate
attenzione invece alle dichiarazioni dei
leaders populisti oggi il giudice non è
la figura che garantisce la legge viene
invitato anzi sfidato a presentarsi alle
elezioni e accontarsi dal punto di vista
della sovranità popolare a verificare il
suo peso il suo consenso rispetto alla
volontà popolare l'altra grande
invenzione della rivoluzione francese
quella sovranità popolare sulla quale si
costruisce il potere e lo stato e in
virtù della quale diventa possibile
rappresentare il popolo
stiamo parlando sempre di artifici
stiamo parlando addirittura come direbbe
e come ha scritto un grande storico e
sociologo della politica francese che si
chiama pià rosanvallon di un sacramento
di un nuovo giuramento il sacramento
elettorale perché l'atto che fonda e
costruisce questa volontà e sovranità
popolare
come sapete è il chiamare il popolo al
voto il popolo si pronuncia esprime la
propria volontà da forma e sostanza alla
sovranità
e un gruppo di governanti si pone come
rappresentante di quella che è la
volontà popolare
questo è l'altro grande e straordinario
prodotto di nuovo enormemente suggestivo
che è la rivoluzione innesta all'interno
la rivoluzione francese innesta
all'interno del pensiero politico perché
di fatto se ci pensiamo
i rappresentanti sono solamente dei
portavoce della volontà popolare e in
questo voi trovate delle interessanti
similitudine una serie di assonanze
rispetto al dibattito politico attuale
particolarmente in italia potremmo dire
perché siamo maggiormente avvezze a
pensare ad un partito non partito ad un
movimento partito politico che ha
definito i suoi parlamentari fino a non
molto tempo fa come niente più che dei
portavoce intercambiabili della volontà
popolare per l'appunto
ma questa idea di volontà popolare quale
viene costruita dalla rivoluzione
prevede per l'appunto che i governanti
eserciti nel proprio potere unicamente
in una connessione diretta con il popolo
questa astrazione che afferisce e
conferisce loro la legittimità ed è
anche per questo che sempre altro
interessante paradosso la rivoluzione
francese e in particolare il club dei
giacobini la frazione più a sinistra
dell'assemblea legislativa nel 1791 fa
promulgare una legge diventata poi molto
molto famosa la sua le cappelle
intitolata naturalmente all'estensore e
firmatario di questa legge che vieta i
corpi intermedi che proclama
l'abolizione di qualunque associazione
di qualunque il raggruppamento di
qualunque struttura organizzata si
frapponesse tra il popolo e il potere
esercitato dai rappresentanti nel nome e
per la volontà del popolo
naturalmente come sempre nella storia
questa legge rispondeva ad un obiettivo
politico molto concreto e molto
specifico per chi club di giacobini era
preoccupato dall'affacciarsi nel
fermento rivoluzionario nell'epoca di
grande trasformazione di grande vivacità
politica delle prime forme di mutualità
di mutualismo operaio le prime forme di
sindacati e naturalmente sostenere che è
tra i rappresentanti e il popolo non ci
dovesse essere nessun corpo intermedio
che interrompesse la trasmissione della
volontà e che quindi producesse un
frazionamento della sovranità popolare
si impiegava sterilizzare ed eliminare
la possibilità che la borghesia si
trovasse i sindacati in casa già alla
fine del settecento però di nuovo i
paradossi o come avrebbe detto vigo i
corsi e ricorsi
oggi ci troviamo nell'epoca della
disintermediazione fortemente agevolata
è facilitata dalle tecnologie digitali
dalle nuove piattaforme che prevede
l'abolizione e la rimozione dei corpi
intermedi
naturalmente questo processo che è
iniziato nella seconda metà degli anni
70 negli stati uniti grazie al progresso
tecnologico per noi consumatori
rappresenta una grande virtù e un grande
beneficio ma come sappiamo benissimo
produce tutta una serie di conseguenze
sulla vita economica e sulla vita
associativa e soprattutto genera delle
enormi implicazioni dal punto di vista
della politica
la disintermediazione è oggi una delle
parole d'ordine come sapete fondamentali
della post politica e dei neo populismi
progredendo o forse retrocedendo lungo
la storia questa idea del popolo come
unità viene abbracciata è sventolata
innalzata nel corso del tempo dai
nazionalismi e dalle varie forme di
proto populismi o cripto populismi che
si affacciano
che sono tutti antiparlamentari perché
il populismo ha una sua essenza profonda
come sapete sono stati scritti scaffali
sulle definizioni di populismo non
esiste non solo populismo naturalmente
ci sono tanti populismi i politologi
presenti in sala ci insegnano che i
populismi sono multiformi che esistono
definizioni e tassonomie tra loro molto
diverse per cercare di racchiudere
l'essenza in maniera molto problematica
è limitata del populismo si è detto che
il populismo è una ideologia sottile che
quindi può abbracciare inserire al
proprio interno materiali ideologici
differenti per cui c'è un populismo di
destra e un populismo di sinistra c'è un
populismo di centro persino pensate a
silvio berlusconi nella fase ascendente
della sua parabola
e c'è un populismo puro c'è un populismo
penale c'è stato un populismo che
potremmo chiamare giustizialismo che
ancora molto molto presente che travasa
elementi e proveniente dalla destra
politica el intreccia innesta su una
dimensione di sinistra
ecco in questi populismi che sono
soprattutto stile comunicativo troviamo
un essenza profonda che ha a che fare
per l'appunto con l'idea che il popolo
sia una unità organica che il popolo non
possa essere scomposto e questa è la
dimensione estremamente artificiale e la
dimensione di simulacro che lo
caratterizza
ma se il popolo si definisce sulla base
dell'unità a un bisogno costante di
identità perché la sua strutturazione è
fondata sullo stare dentro rispetto ad
una serie di soggetti di individui di
associazioni che stanno fuori
e allora grattando nuovamente la
superficie del populismo troviamo che il
populismo e sostanzialmente escludente e
allora ancora oggi appunto nell'epoca
dei neo populismi trionfo
tanti e arrembanti troviamo che i
populismi si definiscono sulla base
della essenza della radice una delle
radici più antiche della politica che
karch mita aveva trovato anche
nell'epoca classica dei greci e dei
romani
la coppia amico nemico si è popolo
quando si è amici dei populisti dei
partiti dei leaders populisti si è si
cessa di essere popolo quando si passa
dalla parte dei nemici e tutto questo ci
racconta due altre cose che hanno molto
a che fare con la nostra epoca di tempi
sempre più accelerati e sempre più
rapidi che è il populismo odierno ha
delle maglie molto larghe molto
flessibili molto elastiche ma si rischia
rapidamente di finire
espulsi dal popolo oggi si è parte del
popolo
domani non è detto che sia così e questo
ci racconta anche come i leaders
populisti siano dei politici
estremamente pragmatici seno dei
politici naturalmente molto scaltri e
molto abili ma anche molto cangianti
molto capaci di mutare come dei
camaleonti perché la nostra è un'epoca
caratterizzata dalla follower leadership
non epoca in cui i leaders non di rado
sulla base di quel sondaggio permanente
che è diventata la nostra politica e che
negli stati uniti era di fatto già
iniziato negli anni trenta con la
sistematizzazione e l'inizio della
tecnicizzazione dei sondaggi da parte di
george che al loop in questa nostra
epoca in cui l'umore di noi cittadini
elettori è molto volatile e tende a
cambiare molto rapidamente
il leader ha bisogno di essere
sintonizzato con i suoi seguaci e quindi
cambia pragmaticamente molto rapidamente
le sue posizioni pur tenendo
naturalmente una serie di convinzioni o
meglio di punti forti perché
maggioritariamente presenti negli stati
d'animo
gli umori della popolazione come fermi
allora provate a pensare ad una
piattaforma digitale presentata come un
strumento di facilitazione della
democrazia diretta e sappiamo perché
sono stati scritti tanti altri scaffali
che il concetto e la categoria di
democrazia diretta è molto complessa
molto articolata
questa piattaforma è stata non a caso
intitolata al ad un celeberrimo filosofo
ginevrino jean jacques rousseau
considerato da buona parte dei giacobini
come il loro riferimento filosofico
ideologico principale la funzione
essenziale di questa piattaforma assai
più che quella di stabilire il rapporto
della democrazia diretta tra i
rappresentanti e rappresentati serve ai
rappresentanti per sintonizzarsi per
capire qual è l'umore dei rappresentati
in certi momenti
oppure serve altra dimensione
fondamentale di quella scatola vuota che
alla fine una parte del populismo serve
a vedersi ratificati e vedersi
confermati i provvedimenti le idee i
presupposti che poi vengono presentati
come espressione della sovranità
popolare
vado rapidamente alla conclusione questa
trasformazione che i neo populismi che
la svolta neopopulista ha introdotto
all'interno della nostra epoca si è
fortemente contaminata con la post
modernità cioè con l'epoca della
accelerazione tecnologica con l'epoca
del la sostanziale archiviazione delle
ideologie delle grandi racconti come li
chiamava jean françois lothar che hanno
dominato l'ottocento e il novecento e
che hanno rappresentato delle
espressioni sostanzialmente di politica
razionale e quindi in un epoca in cui
non esistono più delle verità con la v
maiuscola ma al più delle verità con la
p minuscola molto circoscritte molto
delimitate molto geograficamente
confinate a luoghi precisi che fanno sì
che i giochi linguistici ovvero che la
lingua sia fondamentale per costruire
anche la politica
i neo populismi hanno adottato e
costruiscono sistematicamente giorno
dopo giorno delle neo lingue tutti
quanti conoscete questo concetto lo ha
reso celebre suo malgrado il grande
george orwell in un romanzo davvero
profetico e che è una sorta di scatola
degli attrezzi di cassetta con le chiavi
giuste per cercare di capire i populismi
che 1984 e che non a caso era una
distopia la neolingua è un processo di
ri semantizzazione cioè di svuotamento
dei significati delle parole ed
invenzione di nuovi significati che non
hanno inventato i neo populisti per la
verità nel dibattito politico
contemporaneo è stato il primo
presidente davvero post moderno degli
stati uniti ronald reagan a farne uno
strumento di spindoctoring e di
battaglia politica efficacissima ma
sempre state ad un'espressione come il
decreto dignità ma anche a tantissime
altre che trovate quotidianamente
presenti nel dibattito pubblico sui
giornali in rete in televisione avete
una dimostrazione molto precisa di cosa
è la neo lingua
sono parole che possono essere riempite
da ciascuno di noi con significati che
sentimentalmente ed emozionalmente
troviamo più gratificanti
oppure sono parole che perdono il
significato originario
pensiamo ad un'altra espressione come
riforma del lavoro per tutta la storia
della modernità
abbiamo concepito e associato la parola
riforma all'idea del progresso all'idea
del miglioramento all'idea
dell'acquisizione e dell'accumulazione
di diritti da un po di tempo a questa
parte riforma è sostanzialmente una
contro riforma ovvero una riduzione dei
diritti
ma per l'appunto è una parola
la neolingua politica non usata
solamente dai populisti a nord del vero
che è diventato un pezzo del nostro
complicato confuso dibattito pubblico in
cui capita troppo spesso che non si
abbia più a che fare con una sola sfera
pubblica ma con una molteplicità di
opinioni pubbliche ovvero di camere
dell'eco e di bolle di filtraggio in cui
i cittadini sono assolutamente in buona
fede ma non capiscono gli altri
cittadini
non parliamo più la stessa lingua e
questo naturalmente è l'inizio della
disintegrazione della democrazia
liberale rappresentativa perché il senso
della democrazia rappresentativa è
quello di trovare i terreni di
mediazione di trovare i terreni di
intesa ovvero quel venirsi incontro
quel cercare di stabilire a metà del
cammino un punto di accordo che è stato
progressivamente criminalizzato dal
punto di vista della neolingua con
espressione come inciucio per cui oggi
cercare principio fondativo della
democrazia rappresentativa
un'intesa con gli avversari significa
essere colpevoli e messi sul banco di
imputato per collaborazionismo con i
nemici
la neolingua è un concetto fondamentale
del neopopulismo così come il pensiero
magico e parlando di pensiero magico
dobbiamo davvero pensare ai grandi
antropologi del novecento allievi b con
yul a malinowsky alle vistose a coloro
che studiarono popolazioni che
naturalmente non avevano vissuto la
storia europea e la cesura
dell'illuminismo
pensate a a proposito di un perfetto
connubio tra la neolingua e il pensiero
magico allo spread o al dio mercato che
diventano i grandi nemici che passano
sopra la nostra testa
e assumono quasi un carattere
trascendente dei populisti e chiaro che
di fronte allo spread un po come
accadrebbe ad una popolazione della
papua nuova guinea studiata da
malinowsky di fronte ad un tifone ad un
triste o un tornado non c'è la
possibilità di resistere
ora non è che il pensiero magico sia un
pensiero totalmente razionale ma come ci
ha raccontato benissimo nella storia
della colonna infame a proposito degli
untori manzoni è un modo per
cauterizzare la paura individuando dei
responsabili dei capri espiatori che non
rispondono ai nessi logici tra causa ed
effetto
e un modo per cercare di dominare la
paura non avendo gli strumenti per
affrontarla e per risolvere i problemi
ed è anche un modo naturalmente perde
responsabilizzarsi cosa può fare un
governo populista di fronte ad una
tempesta ordita dalla banca centrale
europea dagli speculatori internazionali
dai mercati come se fossero dei totem se
non cercare di resistere alla bell e
meglio ma se viene sconfitto non è colpa
sua non ne porta alcuna responsabilità
ecco questa dimensione del neopopulismo
è una dimensione che la post modernità
ha reso molto più efficace molto più
penetrante grazie alle tecnologie della
comunicazione grazie alle ai siti e
allora non esiste il popolo ma esistono
i populismi e cosa suoni neo populismi
se il popolo non esiste sono di volta in
volta dei partiti personali in cui la
dimensione del leader è centrale questa
naturalmente non è una novità è una
dimensione strutturale del populismo
sono delle metodologie neo plebiscitaria
ho però la reinvenzione nella nostra
epoca di tarda modernità del fatto che
il popolo deve sostanzialmente
plebiscitari una serie di decisioni di
provvedimenti o di proposte politiche
che vengono per l'appunto da questi
leader e infine e soprattutto potremmo
dire chi è né o populismi sono una forma
di demagoghi cazione una crasi tra la
demagogia e la comunicazione post
moderna infatti i populismi senza
leaders e senza comunicazione efficace
rischiano rischiano lo dico in termini
neutrale in termini avrebbe ariana mente
a valutativi di essere portati via e
riconsegnati ad una dimensione eterna
della storia ma questo tutto sommato
pensandoci non sarebbe un grande male
per coloro che tengono molto alla difesa
e alla salvaguardia delle democrazie
liberali rappresentative molte grazie
[Applauso]